this is the third time in nfl history a
game was played on a wednesday
and the baltimore ravens were forced to
face the pittsburgh steelers without
their star quarterback
after lamar jackson and at least a dozen
others tested positive for covet 19.
but this is just the latest nfl outbreak
with four weeks still to go
in the regular season do you think the
nfl will be able to
end its season as scheduled um i don't
know
i i hope so um but i don't know if
anybody can predict
you know what the future uh and how
that's gonna unfold
demario davis is a linebacker for the
new orleans saints
the nfl fined the team last month after
davis and others were captured on social
media
celebrating maskless when you first walk
out off the field out the wind
you got so many emotions you don't
naturally think hey go put a mask on
but those protocols are in place and you
know
we're not going to be wants to defy the
protocols
intentionally since then we still do our
locker room celebration we just put our
mask on
and i just i think it's just that we
want to continue to
push that message that it's going to
take all of us
wednesday the nfl reported that between
november 22nd and 28th
there were 86 newly confirmed cases of
the virus
the highest total since the league began
testing in august
nfl commissioner roger goodell we're
seeing uh
virus spread and increase in our
communities and so
that's a challenge for us but we believe
that the protocols that we've
established are working
obviously our objective is to finish 256
games
safely now with the playoffs fast
approaching and let's not forget the
super bowl february 7th goodell also
says
he does not believe the nfl needs to
create
a bubble as the nba did to protect its
players but he is open to
some type of isolation and other ways to
reduce
risk mario davis tells us everyone here
is just trying to do
the best they can tony all right aaron
uh not er errol barnett yeah a lot of
that
matt attacking ray filmmaker a lot of
people hope that they can pull this off
they're gonna have somebody standing
there they give them mass when they
first walk off because
you're all caught up in the moment i get
it no i understand